On me demande très souvent comment
est-ce qu'on peut accéder aux communautés,
comment on peut aller
visiter des communautés.
Ça peut être une question assez délicate,
parce que c'est comme si je disais
« Si je veux aller visiter Saint-Lin,
est-ce que je vais rentrer chez quelqu'un
et lui demander "heille, parle-moi de Saint-Lin,
parle-moi de ta culture!" »
C'est c'est la même chose
dans les communautés ou dans les réserves
ou même dans les organismes
en milieu urbain.
Il ne faut pas oublier
qu'on est des Premières Nations,
mais qu'on ne vient pas au monde avec le devoir
ou l'obligation, même des fois le goût,
d'expliquer tout le temps notre culture
à tout le monde.
Mais on aime que les gens
s'intéressent à notre culture.
Donc, il faut choisir
des moments
et des portes d'entrée pour rentrer
dans les communautés. Le meilleur, meilleur accès,
je le dis tout le temps,
c'est les pow-wow.
Le pow-wow, c'est un moment
qui est ouvert à tout le monde,
que tu sois Autochtones, non Autochtone,
c'est un moment de fête.
C'est un moment où tu peux acheter
de l'artisanat, manger de la nourriture locale.
C'est le temps d'aller dans une
communauté. Quand vous voyez « pow-wow »,
ce n'est pas uniquement pour les gens
de la communauté, c'est pour tout le monde.
Alors, c'est le temps d'y aller et
d'apprendre avec respect la culture
de plusieurs nations qui sont là
et qui échangent entre elles.
On a aussi des événements qui vont être moins liés
sur la culture, mais des fois ça peut être
des tournois de hockey, ça peut être des
festivals de musique comme Innu Nikamu
à Maliotenam. Il y a des moments
d'échanges culturels ou d'activités
sportives qui sont ouverts
à tout le monde.
Des fois, par exemple, il y a des moments
où on demande au public non-autochtone
ou à ceux qui n'ont pas été invités de
ne pas aller aux événements.
Ça peut être de grands rassemblements ou même
de se promener dans le village les vitres montées
comme si c'était le zoo de Saint-Félicien,
« Ah, on regarde les Premières Nations. »
Ce n'est pas comme ça qu'on va se faire des amis.
Alors, la meilleur manière,
c'est souvent de créer une relation
avec un individu qui va t'inviter chez lui,
comme n'importe quel Québécois ferait
pour faire visiter sa localité ou sa ville.
Et après ça, quand c'est fait dans
le respect quand c'est fait sur du long terme,
Tu peux juste après ça
développer d'autres amitiés et découvrir
la nation et la culture et la communauté
d'une façon beaucoup plus saine
que si on faisait
un zoo anthropologique.
J'espère que vous n'allez pas hésiter à partager
des moments que vous avez apprécié
quand vous êtes allés dans des communautés
et que vous n'allez pas hésiter non plus à prendre
des risques, parce que je sais que ça
peut être intimidant
le premier contact avec une nouvelle culture,
surtout quand c'est une culture
que ça fait 500 ans avec laquelle
vous partagez le territoire, mais que vous
n'avez pas encore été visiter.
Mais je peux vous dire qu'il n'y a personne
qui n'est jamais venue me voir en disant
« C'était la pire erreur de ma vie. »
C'est souvent le contraire qu'on me dit.
Donc, merci pour la question. N'hésitez pas
à nous en envoyer d'autres à Espaces autochtones
et je vous souhaite une très belle semaine.